Jake: 都戳一下
Jake: Everyone, mark it.
Jake: 每人戳一下
Jake: Each person, mark it.
Jake: 传过去戳一下哎
Jake: Pass it around and mark it, hey.
Jake: 你能看到对吗
Jake: You can see it, right?
Jake: 好戳完了
Jake: Alright, all marked.
Jake: 行
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 开机开
Jake: Start it up.
Jake: 开机开那
Jake: 那
Jake: Well.
Jake: 啊就是今天我们就讨论讨论
Jake: So today we will discuss.
Jake: 早上讨论
Jake: This morning's discussion.
Jake: 讨论我们最后一天干点啥呗
Jake: Let's discuss what to do on our last day.
Jake: 然后可能
Jake: And then maybe...
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 就是这边还有4个
Jake: There are still 4 of these.
Jake: 这个USB就可能这
Jake: This USB, maybe this...
Jake: 这叫什么
Jake: What's it called?
Jake: 这个硬盘
Jake: This hard drive.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 早上我觉得大家主要是讨论
Jake: I think the main focus this morning is discussion.
Jake: 然后讨论的时候闲着没事
Jake: And while discussing, if there's nothing to do...
Jake: 如果大家陷入了沉思
Jake: If everyone falls into deep thought...
Jake: 陷入了尴尬
Jake: Or it gets awkward...
Jake: 可以把这个给装一装
Jake: You can put this together.
Jake: 对只是一个back up
Jake: It's just a backup.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 所以
Jake: So...
Jake: 现在就尴尬了啊
Jake: Now it's awkward, huh.
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Shure:  没有没有
Shure: No, no.
Shure: 先看拆了看看是什么
Shure: Let's take it apart first and see what it is.
Jake: 行那也行那也行
Jake: Okay, that works too.
Shure:  哇哦
Shure: Wow.
Lucia: 哎
Lucia: Hey.
Lucia: 只有4个吗
Lucia: Only 4 of them?
Jake: 对只有4个
Jake: Yes, only 4.
Lucia: 没事没事
Lucia: It's fine, it's fine.
Lucia: 我拆过这个
Lucia: I've taken this apart before.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Jake: 因为你是menter
Jake: Because you're a mentor.
Jake: 啊对
Jake: Oh, right.
Lucia: 哈哈我已经装过这个东西了
Lucia: Haha, I've already assembled this thing before.
Shure:  需要充电宝在这里拿
Shure: If you need a power bank, take one from here.
Lucia: 好的谢谢
Lucia: Okay, thanks.
Jake: 我先把这些端走
Jake: I'll move these away first.
Katrina: 哇还有螺丝呀
Katrina: Wow, there are screws too.
Jake: 好，大家拆出来了可以摆成什么样呢
Jake: Alright, everyone, once you've taken it apart, how can we arrange it?
Jake: 摆成
Jake: Arrange it...
Jake: 这个盒子要留着
Jake: We need to keep this box.
Jake: 嗯里边这个东西可以丢掉
Jake: Hmm, this thing inside can be thrown away.
Jake: 这东西都丢掉吧
Jake: Just throw all these things away.
Shure:  这眼镜布留着
Jake: Keep this cleaning cloth.
Jake: 好那就先摆成这样
Jake: Okay, let's arrange it like this for now.
Jake: 这个是等大家陷入沉思的时候再用
Jake: We'll use this when everyone gets deep in thought.
Jake: 但是这个我可以跟大家先讲一下
Jake: But I can explain this to everyone first.
Jake: 这个东西是什么呢
Jake: What is this thing?
Jake: 就大家可以看这个地方
Jake: Everyone can look at this part.
Jake: 你们也看不见这个地方
Jake: You guys can't see this part.
Jake: 或者你们过来吧
Jake: Or you can come over.
Jake: 走动走动
Jake: Come on over.
Jake: 就是看我的工作间
Jake: Just look at my workspace.
Shure:  我们这算私闯闺房吗
Shure: Are we trespassing into your private space?
Jake: 那请请请请
Jake: Please, please, come in.
Jake: 工作间
Jake: Workspace.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Jake: 然后这地方是一共有6台电脑对吧
Jake: So, there are six computers here, right?
Jake: 嗯后这7台
Jake: Then seven.
Jake: 8台
Jake: Eight.
Jake: 嗯
Jake: Hmm.
Jake: 9台 10台
Jake: Nine, ten.
Jake: 但是就是这边6台电脑
Jake: But there are six computers here.
Jake: 每一个电脑
Jake: Each computer...
Jake: 都对应着你们的一台眼镜
Jake: Corresponds to one of your pairs of glasses.
Jake: 然后这个每一台电脑
Jake: And then every computer
Jake: 你们每次录完结束
Jake: Every time you finish recording
Jake: 每隔三个小时
Jake: Every three hours
Jake: 然后会嗯就是在这儿导到这个硬盘里边
Jake: Then it will be imported into this hard drive
Jake: 然后这个硬盘
Jake: And this hard drive
Jake: 就是你们一会要装的硬盘
Jake: Is the one you need to install later
Shure: 嗷
Shure: Oh
Jake: 就是比方说这个这个L1这个L1这个L2
Jake: For example, this L1, this L1, this L2
Jake: 然后这个名字的名字都写在这了
Jake: The names are all written here
Jake: 哈哈哈你们的数据都在这个里边
Jake: Hahaha, all your data is in here
Shure:  这我们的第二生命
Shure: This is our second life
Lucia: 呵呵呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehehe
Jake: 对你们的第二生命都在这个里边啊
Jake: Yes, your second life is all in here
Jake: 比方说我这个L1
Jake: For example, this L1
Jake: 对吧然后你们结束之后
Jake: Right, then after you finish
Jake: 就是会把这个眼睛插到这个上面
Jake: You will plug this eye into here
Jake: 然后同时
Jake: And at the same time
Jake: 现在一直接着这个第一个硬盘
Jake: Now keep connecting to this first hard drive
Jake: 对然后这个硬盘它有两根线
Jake: Yes, and this hard drive has two cables
Jake: 一个是一个是接电脑的
Jake: One is connected to the computer
Jake: 一个是接电源的
Jake: The other is for power
Jake: 然后这个电源
Jake: And this power
Jake: 是为了让这个硬盘假装自己在电脑上
Jake: Is to make the hard drive pretend it's in the computer
Jake:呵呵 所以这个盒的意思就是说
Jake: Hehe, so the box means
Jake: 他给模拟一个电脑的环境
Jake: It simulates a computer environment
Shure: 诱骗器
Shure: Deceiver
Jake: 然后用硬盘对对
Jake: And then use the hard drive, yes
Jake:对对 让硬盘能知道自己要工作了
Jake: Yes, to let the hard drive know it has to work
Jake: 对啊然后这个线啊
Jake: Yeah, and then this cable
Jake: 这个线我们我们布线还挺有意思的
Jake: This cable, our wiring is quite interesting
Jake: 就长成这个样子
Jake: It looks like this
Shure: 是一个悬着的啊
Shure: It's hanging, huh
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure: 那如果突然停电了会怎么样
Shure: What if the power suddenly goes out?
Jake: 那不好讲
Jake: That would be hard to say.
Jake: 就是电脑突然停电
Jake: The computer would just shut down.
Jake: 就是会很尴尬
Jake: It would be really awkward.
Shure:  那没有什么
Shure: Well, there's nothing...
Shure:  就是USB之类的
Shure: Like, there's no USB or anything?
Shure:  嗯就是那种备用电源
Shure: Like, some backup power supply?
Jake: 哦哦没有
Jake: Oh, no, we don't.
Jake: 还没那么有钱
Jake: We're not that rich yet.
Jake: 我们只能相信这个别墅
Jake: We just have to trust this villa.
Jake: 或者相信北京电力吧
Jake: Or trust Beijing Electricity.
Shure:  感谢
Shure: Thanks.
Jake: 好你们都开始装了
Jake: Alright, you guys start setting up.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  我们可以可以边聊边装吧
Shure: We can chat while setting up, right?
Jake:可以边聊边装嘛
Jake: We can chat while setting up?
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Jake: 对嗯或者说你们先带你们带点什么吧
Jake: Yeah, or maybe you guys show what you brought.
Jake: 你们带点什么
Jake: What did you bring?
Jake: 哎这个这个眼镜你得带好
Jake: Hey, make sure to handle these glasses carefully.
Lucia: 你最好站到那边
Lucia: You better stand over there.
Jake: 这眼镜
Jake: These glasses...
Jake: 嗯也不能遮住
Jake: Yeah, don't block it.
Jake: 应该都不没遮住吧
Jake: Shouldn't be blocking, right?
Jake: 现在没遮住
Jake: Not blocking now.
Lucia:  但这里有一个孔
Jake: But there's a hole here.
Lucia: 然后这个地方是要坐在这的
Lucia: And this part should sit here.
Lucia: 所以你要就是最好这样对齐
Lucia: So you should align it like this.
Lucia: 然后慢慢往里推
Lucia: And push it in slowly.
Lucia: 看怎么样能推进去
Lucia: See how it fits.
Lucia: 好像要轻一点
Lucia: Seems like you need to be gentle.
Lucia: 那天那同学跟我说这个挺脆弱的
Lucia: A classmate told me this is pretty fragile.
Jake: 嗯对就是
Jake: Yeah, right...
Shure:  没事搞定
Shure: No worries, got it.
Lucia: 就是这不是有一个口吗
Lucia: 跟这个是对着的
Lucia: 你就像他们这样对着
Lucia: 然后慢慢推
Lucia: 看这样手里能有推进去
Lucia: 要稍微使点力气
Lucia: 他这还是有一点紧的
Lucia: 但是需要别太使劲
Lucia: 别掰坏了
Shure:  没有吧
Lucia: 好像很脆弱的样子
Lucia: 不过我其实也不是很懂这个
Jake: 有有有很多螺丝
Lucia: 要拧螺丝
Jake: 对
Shure: 那螺丝呢
Lucia: 在那里面
Shure:  哦懂了
Shure:  easy
Shure: Easy.
Katrina:  然后就把它装进去了
Katrina: And then just put it in.
Lucia: 嗯对然后要装到这个盒子里
Lucia: Yeah, and then you need to put it in this box.
Lucia: 就是你最好是把这个地方取下来
Lucia: You should probably remove this part.
Lucia: 然后这个片就可以不要了
Lucia: And you won't need this piece.
Lucia: 因为这里一会要也要用来拧螺丝
Lucia: Because you'll need to use this part to screw later.
Alice: 是不是只要拧4个螺丝
Alice: Do we only need to screw in 4 screws?
Lucia: 呃8个
Lucia: Uh, 8 screws.
Lucia: 呃8个 8个吗
Lucia: Uh, 8 screws. 8, right?
Alice:：8个吗
Alice: 8 screws?
Alice: 对
Alice: Right.
Shure: 是的
Shure: Yes.
Lucia: 就是你你把那个条抽出来
Lucia: So, you need to pull out that strip.
Lucia: 对然后就你看到那个孔了没
Lucia: Yes, then do you see that hole?
Lucia: 长条形那个
Lucia: The long one.
Lucia: 他那里面也有一个螺丝孔
Lucia: There's a screw hole in there too.
Lucia: 你要把那个也上上
Lucia: You need to screw that one in too.
Lucia: 就是那个是大螺丝的螺丝孔
Lucia: That's the screw hole for the big screw.
Katrina:  啊哪个
Tasha: Uh, which one?
Lucia: 呃这里，你看
Lucia: Uh, here, look.
Alice:我已经上上完一个螺丝
Alice: I already finished screwing one in.
Lucia: 就是这个这个东西
Lucia: It's this thing right here.
Lucia: 嗯我怎么样给你指的比较清楚
Lucia: Hmm, how do I point this out clearly to you?
Lucia: 哎你上的这是对的
Lucia: Oh, what you did is correct.
Alice: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Lucia: 对然后这边每个都有
Lucia: Yes, and there's one on each side.
Lucia: 然后这个也是所以一共是有8个
Lucia: And this one too, so there are 8 in total.
Lucia: 对的
Lucia: Right.
Alice:嗷懂了
Alice: Oh, I understand.
Alice: 看见了
Alice: I see.
Katrina:  看见了这是大螺丝
Katrina: I see, this is the big screw.
Katrina:  你看在这
Katrina: Look, it's here.
Alice:对对小螺丝上这对
Lucia: Yeah, the small screw goes here.
Alice: 哦里边是把它插进去就行了吧
Alice: Oh, just insert it inside, right?
Alice: 就那个
Alice: Just that.
Alice: 就那个对
Alice: Just that, right?
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Alice: 呃那个对
Alice: Uh, that one, right.
Alice: 嗯
Alice: Hmm.
Lucia: 里面应该是插进去就行
Lucia: It should just go inside.
Katrina:  集成电路还是什么
Katrina: Integrated circuit or what?
Lucia: 充电路还是什么
Jake: 上一回我们一直在抱怨磁吸的问题
Jake: Last time, we kept complaining about the magnetic issue.
Jake: 但是好像今天大家都没有什么
Jake: But it seems like today no one has any...
Lucia: 对今天大家好像接受良好
Lucia: Yeah, everyone seems to accept it well today.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Shure:  毕毕竟附赠的这个不可能给你
Shure: After all, the freebie can't give you...
Lucia: 就是就是
Lucia: Yeah, exactly.
Lucia: 这个螺丝刀它没有磁性
Lucia: This screwdriver doesn't have magnetism.
Lucia: 对所以就是在
Lucia: Yeah, so when placing the screws, it's very...
Lucia: 放螺丝的时候就很麻
Lucia: Yeah, this is for enlarging.
Lucia: 对是这里是放大的
Lucia: Yeah, the big one can snap in.
Katrina:  嗯大的能卡进去
Katrina: Hmm, the big one can snap in.
Lucia: 呃他就是这样子
Lucia: Uh, it's like this.
Lucia: 他没有办法就穿过这个孔
Lucia: It can't pass through this hole.
Lucia: 你就是要把它固定这样子就可以了
Lucia: You just need to secure it like this and it's fine.
Jake:你的头发总喜欢挡着镜头
Jake: Your hair always blocks the camera.
Jake: 要不想想办法
Jake: Can you do something about it?
Jake: 对或者塞到里边去
Jake: Or maybe tuck it in.
Lucia: 应该是只要把它固定住就好
Lucia: I think as long as we secure it, it should be fine.
Lucia: 是是这样吗
Lucia: Is that right?
Jake: 嗯这个好
Jake: Yeah, this is good.
Shure:  我们
Shure: We...
Shure:  是不是可以有一点BGM
Shure: Can we have some background music?
Lucia: 支持
Lucia: I'm in!
Shure:  大家平时爱听什么类型的音乐
Shure: What kind of music do you all usually listen to?
Katrina:  我我听陶喆
Katrina: I listen to David Tao.
Jake: 陶喆类型的音乐
Jake: David Tao kind of music?
Jake: 嗯RMB RMB
Jake: Hmm, RMB, RMB.
Lucia: 我是混欧美圈的
Lucia: I'm into Western music.
Lucia: 所以就乱听
Lucia: So I just listen to random stuff.
Alice: 给大家一个比较干劲的
Alice: Give everyone something energetic.
Katrina:  好，那个东北御姐的BGM
Katrina: Okay, that Northeastern queen BGM.
Shure:  哈哈哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Jake:来自东方
Jake: From the East.
Alice: 干活的时候必须贼有劲
Alice: We need something really motivating while working.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 来跳吧要不然
Jake: How about we dance?
Shure:  我想扛起来了
Shure: I'm ready to lift it up.
Katrina: 扛起来
Katrina: Lift it up.
Shure:  呵呵呵
Shure: Hehe.
Shure:  这个半嵌入就行是吧
Shure: This semi-embedded is fine, right?
Shure:  这样对对
Shure: Like this.
Jake: 对对古蔺游戏
Jake: Yeah, yeah, the Gulian game.
Katrina:  OK
Katrina: OK.
Shure: 大东北
Shure: Big Northeast.
Shure:  我的家乡
Shure: My hometown.
Jake: 你东北哪的呀
Jake: Which part of Northeast?
杨Shure: 我 稻花香
Shure: Rice fragrance.
Jake: 东北稻花的
Jake: Northeast rice fragrance?
Shure:  不是不是
Shure: No, no.
Shure:  那个长春的
Shure: Changchun.
Jake: 长春的
Jake: Changchun.
Shure: 吉林省长春市
Shure: Changchun City, Jilin Province
Shure:  大家知道这个城市吗
Shure: Does everyone know this city?
Katrina: 知道呀
Katrina: Yes, I do.
Lucia: 知道
Lucia: I know it.
Shure:  大家知道吉林省还有个吉林市吗
Shure: Do you also know there's a Jilin City in Jilin Province?
Alice:啊
Alice: Ah
Jake:对这也知道
Jake: Yes, I know this too.
Jake: 怎么你在吉林市
Jake: So, are you in Jilin City?
Shure:  没有我在长春
Jake: No, I'm in Changchun.
Jake: 你们隔壁 是吧
Jake: You guys are neighbors, right?
Shure: 好像是
Jake: Seems like it.
Shure:  大东北
Shure: The northeast.
Shure:  AI人类为什么喜欢听这样的音乐
Shure: Why do AI humans like listening to this kind of music?
Lucia: 人类迷惑行为
Lucia: Human confusion behavior.
Jake: 然后这边有一个螺丝
Jake: Then there's a screw here.
Jake: 你看两边
Jake: Look at both sides.
Lucia: 外面这好像不装回去也
Lucia: It seems like you don't need to put it back.
Lucia: 也可以就这个条
Lucia: Just this strip is okay.
Lucia: 我们那天反正好像都扔了我记得
Lucia: I remember we threw it away the other day.
Shure:  这条刚好
Shure: This strip fits perfectly.
Lucia: 这条可以扔是吧
Lucia: This strip can be thrown away, right?
Jake: 可以放可以放
Jake: You can put it, you can put it.
Jake: 我昨天成功的放了进去
Jake: I successfully put it in yesterday.
Lucia: 哦哦原来如此
Lucia: Oh, I see.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Lucia: 那那那咱那天的嘞
Lucia: Then what about the one we had the other day?
Jake: 没关系
Jake: It's okay.
Jake: 它就是美观
Jake: It's just for aesthetics.
Jake: 它就是看的没有螺丝
Jake: It looks better without the screw.
Jake: 然后把它这样
Jake: And then put it like this.
Shure: 可以进厂了
Shure: You can go into the factory now.
Alice: 可以我已经进过厂了
Alice: I can. I've already been to the factory.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Jake: 啊你你进过厂玩过
Jake: Ah, you've been to the factory?
Alice: 我觉得我们大学那些接线的
Alice: I think our university's wiring and soldering work is no different from being in a factory.
Alice: 焊板子的跟进厂没啥区别
Alice: Soldering boards, it's just like being in a factory.
Jake: 物联网吗
Jake: The Internet of Things?
Jake: 还是什么
Jake: Or something else?
Alice: 对电工
Alice: Yeah, electrical work.
Lucia:呃对电工实习会做一些神奇的东西 我们学校也是
Lucia: Uh, yeah, electrical internships make you do some interesting things. Our school does that too.
Jake: 最后最后放成这个样子
Jake: Finally, just put it like this.
Jake: 好吧然后就就可以出叫出场了对
Jake: Alright, then it can be launched, right?
Jake: 出流水线
Jake: Out of the production line.
Jake: 下一个流水线
Jake: Next production line.
Lucia: 下一个流水线是让你接到电脑上的
Lucia: The next production line is to connect to the computer.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure:  下一个需要高级技工
Shure: The next one needs a senior technician.
Lucia: 哈哈哈高级技工
Lucia: Hahaha, senior technician.
Katrina: 3,000
Katrina: 3,000.
Jake: 3,000的技工到5,000的技工
Jake: A technician from 3,000 to 5,000.
Shure:  你说的这是技工吗
Shure: Is that what you call a technician?
Alice: 什么是技工
Alice: What's a technician?
Lucia: 技术工人
Lucia: A technical worker.
Shure:  哎为什么我
Shure: Hey, why me?
Alice: 因为你按反了啊
Alice: Because you pressed it the wrong way!
Jake: 这个是有俩螺丝啊
Jake: This has two screws.
Jake: 锁呢哎哎
Jake: The lock, hey hey.
Shure:  完了太丢人了
Shure: Oh no, so embarrassing.
Shure: 倒数第一了
Shure: Last place.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure: 不行我必须要争一下
Shure: No, I have to compete.
Shure:  我不能倒数第一
Shure: I can't be last.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha.
Jake: 哈哈好
Jake: 硬盘硬盘锦标赛就不用干什么了吗
Jake: Hard drive championship, then nothing else to do?
Katrina: 就不用干什么了吗
Katrina: Nothing else to do?
Lucia: 拧完应该就就好了
Lucia: Once you finish screwing, it should be fine.
Shure: 他风轻云淡的说一句拧完了
Shure: He casually says, "Once you finish screwing."
Shure:  然后
Shure: Then...
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  他挑衅我
Shure: He provokes me.
Shure:  我靠
Shure: Damn
Jake:到底还有机会吗
Jake: Do we still have a chance?
Katrina:  是这样吗
Katrina: Is that so?
Lucia: 应该是吧
Lucia: I think so.
Lucia: 好了吧
Lucia: Is it done?
Jake: 对对对放到这个盒子里面
Jake: Yeah, yeah, put it in this box.
Jake: 你看你没有装上那一关
Jake: Look, you missed that part.
Alice:条不用装
Alice: No need to install the strip.
Jake: 对这就是最后一步
Jake: Yes, this is the last step.
Lucia: 条装不装都行，不装的话，挺麻烦的
Lucia: Whether you install the strip or not, it can be a hassle if you don’t.
Jake: 给你一点机会但是你还是没有抓住
Jake: I gave you a chance but you still didn’t take it.
Jake: 你可以把条放在里面
Jake: You can put the strip inside.
Lucia: 如果需要装的话
Lucia: If it needs to be installed.
Lucia: 然后尽量自己装就好了
Lucia: Then try to do it yourself.
Jake: 没需要装完全没必要放里面就好
Jake: If it doesn’t need to be installed, just leave it out.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK
Lucia: 伊，怎么盖不上
Lucia: Eh, why can’t it close?
Shure:  他已经可以出场了
Shure: It’s ready to go.
Jake:出场
Jake: Ready to go.
Jake: 好谢谢大家
Jake: Alright, thanks everyone.
Jake: 完成了一个奇怪的第一次任务
Jake: We completed a weird first task.
Jake: 然后这个EGO life最后一天
Jake: And this is the last day of EGO life.
Jake: 大家会邀请什么人呢
Jake: Who will everyone invite?
Shure:  啊最后一天
Shure: Ah, the last day.
Jake: 最后一天
Jake: The last day.
Shure:  最后一天是周日是吗
Shure: The last day is Sunday, right?
Jake: 是周周日周日下午吧
Jake: Yeah, Sunday afternoon.
Shure:  啊大家会邀请什么人
Shure: Ah, who will everyone invite?
Jake: 会邀请几个人
Jake: How many people will we invite?
Jake: 呀
Jake: Yeah.
Shure: 黑板写一写吧
Shure: Write it on the board.
Jake: 对黑板可以写一写
Jake: Yes, we can write it on the board.
Shure:  来我来我字非常好看
Shure: Let me, my handwriting is great.
Jake: 好的
Jake: Alright.
Jake: 我们还有一个架子
Jake: We still have a stand.
Jake: 要不我们也拼一下好
Jake: How about we put it together?
Shure:  什么架子
Shure: What stand?
Shure:  就是黑板架啊
Shure: The blackboard stand.
Jake: 你如果觉得这个这么写很难写的话
Jake: If you think it’s hard to write like this...
Jake: 它其实有一个
Jake: Actually, it has a...
Shure:  没有笔
Shure: No pen.
Jake: 就这个东西就是你可以假装再装吧
Jake: This thing, you can just pretend and keep pretending.
Shure:  行
Shure: Okay.
Jake:问题不大是吧
Jake: It's not a big problem, right?
Shure:  不影响我这个书法的发挥
Shure: It won't affect my calligraphy.
Jake: 笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Shure: 笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Shure: 好问题
Shure: Good question.
Jake:好问题
Jake: Good question.
Lucia: 嗯
Lucia: Hmm.
Shure:  问问他问问AI
Shure: Ask him, ask AI.
Shure:  笔呢
Shure: Where's the pen?
Jake:笔呢
Jake: Where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的iPhone吗
Lucia: Find my iPhone?
Jake: 哈哈哈对笔呢
Jake: Hahaha, yeah, where's the pen?
Lucia: 寻找我的
Lucia: Find my...
Lucia: 寻找我的pencil
Lucia: Find my pencil.
Jake: 笔应该在上面
Jake: The pen should be up there.
Jake: 等一下啊
Jake: Wait a sec.
Shure:  我们都是iPhone
Shure: We all have iPhones.
Lucia: 好像应该是
Lucia: Seems like it.
Alice: 我是ePhone
Alice: I have an ePhone.
Shure:  咦什么烂梗啊哈哈哈
Shure: Eh, what a lame joke, hahaha.
Lucia: 啊这是个梗吗
Lucia: Ah, was that a joke?
Lucia: 我为什么没有改到
Lucia: Why didn't I get it?
Katrina:  他是e人
Katrina: He's an e-person.
Lucia: 哦哦OK
Lucia: Oh, okay.
Lucia: 哎所以我们的e人到底是哪两位啊
Lucia: So, who are our e-people?
Shure: 我我也是一
Shure: Me, I'm also one.
Lucia: 哎你是一吗
Lucia: Eh, are you one?
Shure:  我我是E不是1啊OK
Shure: I'm E, not 1, okay?
Jake:有啥差别啊
Jake: What's the difference?
Jake: 啊你是1哦
Jake: Oh, you're 1, huh?
Lucia: 所以哎那我们是
Lucia: So, eh, then we are...
Lucia: 三三一两
Lucia: Three-three-one-two.
Lucia: 哎那咱俩是然后呢
Lucia: So, we two are... then what?
Lucia: 啊OK昨天我没有
Lucia: Ah, OK, yesterday I didn't
Lucia: 昨天我没有猜出来
Lucia: Yesterday I didn't guess it
Lucia: 虽然我猜到他可能是E人
Lucia: Even though I guessed he might be an E person
Shure: EGO life
Shure:  最后一天的名单
Shure: The final day's list
Jake:行啊
Jake: Alright
Shure:  你
Shure: You
Shure:  喵
Shure: Meow
Jake:哈哈是这么写的
Jake: Haha, that's how you write it
Jake: 笔画
Jake: Strokes
Shure: 11是这么写的
Shure: That's how you write 11
Jake: 是这么写的
Jake: That's how you write it
Shure:  夹怎么写
Shure: How do you write "夹"?
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 啊太久没写
Shure: Ah, I haven't written in so long
Tasha: 宝盖头
Tasha: Roof radical
Lucia: 宝盖头
Lucia: Roof radical
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure:  OK第一位
Shure: OK, first one
Jake: 小硕你邀请几个人啊
Jake: Shure, how many people are you inviting?
Shure:  我浅浅邀一个吧
Shure: I'll just invite one casually
Shure:  浅
Shure: Casually
Jake:浅浅先邀一个啊
Jake: Alright, just invite one casually
Jake: 鲁亚呢
Jake: How about Luya?
Lucia: 我不太确定因为咱们这太远了
Lucia: I'm not sure because it's too far
Lucia: 我不知道我小伙伴过不过得来
Lucia: I don't know if my friends can make it
Jake: 好那你的工作室
Jake: Okay, then your studio
Tasha: 我浅浅邀请一个吧
Tasha: I'll just invite one casually
Jake: 好浅浅邀请一个
Jake: Alright, just invite one casually
Shure:  叫什么名字
Shure: What's the name?
Jake: 用不着用不着
Jake: No need, no need
Jake: 这就用不
Jake: That's not necessary
Jake: 着了就是大概画个正字得了
Jake: Just roughly make a tally mark
Shure:  啊画正字好
Shure: Ah, tally mark is fine
Jake: 或者你用那个小球
Jake: Or you can use those small balls
Jake: 我估计也够
Jake: I think that should be enough
Katrina:  画小人吧
Katrina: Just draw little people
Katrina:  男生就是这样
Katrina: Boys are like this
Katrina:  女生夹两边
Katrina: Girls have sides
Shure:  你邀请哈哈哈
Shure: You invite hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Tasha: 这是你邀请的女生吗
Tasha: Is this the girl you invited?
Shure:  啊你呢
Shure: Ah, what about you?
Tasha: 那我也邀请一位女生
Tasha: Then I'll invite a girl too.
Lucia: 你这个你这个辫
Lucia: This, this braid...
Lucia: 他这个接口没有在头上
Lucia: This connection isn't on the head.
Katrina:  这个假发我的天呐
Katrina: This wig, oh my god.
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Shure: 我们冲天一下哎
Shure: Let's go wild for a bit.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Katrina: 我应该邀请一个男生
Katrina: I should invite a guy.
Shure:  男生
Shure: A guy?
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Alice: 我爱心童的
Alice: I love Heart Child.
Katrina: 哈哈三条腿
Katrina: Haha, three legs.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Jake:这合适吧这样
Jake: Is this appropriate like this?
Shure:  对不起不小心画出头
Shure: Sorry, I accidentally drew the head.
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: OK
Lucia: 我其实可以问一个女生
Lucia: Actually, I can ask a girl.
Lucia: 但我不确定她能不能过得来
Lucia: But I'm not sure if she can come.
Lucia: 因为他那边挺远的
Lucia: Because she's quite far away.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈存疑是吧
Lucia: Hahaha, uncertain, right?
Shure: 存疑
Shure: Uncertain.
Jake: 还有你可以在每个人下面写一个名字
Jake: And you can write a name under each person.
Jake: 写一个他的host
Jake: Write their host.
Shure:  host是吗
Shure: Host, right?
Jake: 嗯就是你的代号
Jake: Yeah, like your code name.
Shure:  嗯认领一下
Shure: Yeah, claim it.
Jake: 不不不
Jake: No, no, no.
Jake: 你就在这个小人的下面写一个
Jake: Just write it under the little person.
Jake: 或者在上面或者脸上写一个之类的
Jake: Or above, or on the face, something like that.
Shure:  这是谁的来着那
Shure: Whose is this again?
Katrina:  呃他上他上
Katrina: Uh, it's up, it's up.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: 然后
Shure: Then...
Alice:这是宇轩的
Alice: This is Yuxuan's.
Katrina:  嗯那写LX LYX
Katrina: Yeah, then write LX, LYX.
Jake: 啊哈哈哈哈
Jake: Ah hahaha
Shure:  这这位是谁的人
Shure: Whose person is this?
Lucia: 我露西或者写个l也行哈哈哈
Lucia: I'm Lucia, or you can just write "L" hahaha
Shure:  啊你要邀请两个是吗
Shure: Ah, you want to invite two people, right?
Alice: 对但是有一个可能来不了
Alice: Yes, but one might not come.
Shure:  性别
Shure: Gender?
Alice:都是女的呵
Alice: They're all women, hehe.
Alice: 有一个不知道能来不能
Alice: One of them might not be able to make it.
Alice: 你给我画个星就行了五角星
Alice: Just draw a star for me, a pentagram.
Shure:  OK
Shure: OK.
Shure:  现在我们有一二三四五六六位嘉宾
Shure: Now we have one, two, three, four, five, six, six guests.
Jake: 嗯呃4-6位嘉宾
Jake: Hmm, uh, 4-6 guests.
Shure:  对 4-6位
Shure: Yes, 4-6 guests.
Jake:4-6位嘉宾OK
Jake: 4-6 guests, OK.
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake: 我们原来还打算有可能的话
Jake: We originally planned, if possible...
Jake: 去邀请周围的人
Jake: ...to invite people from around.
Shure:  啊
Shure: Ah.
Jake:对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 就是或者小红书
Jake: Or from Xiaohongshu.
Jake: 还是
Jake: Or...
Lucia: 是采取挨家挨户敲门询问的方式吗
Lucia: Are we going door-to-door to ask?
Jake: 呃
Jake: Uh...
Jake:反正
Jake: Anyway...
Alice: 提一篮子鸡蛋比较好
Alice: Bringing a basket of eggs might be better.
Jake: 环球影城门口直接抓人
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Lucia: 确实如果如
Lucia: Indeed, if they come...
Lucia: 果就是如果他们来的话可以发鸡蛋什么的
Lucia: ...we could give out eggs or something.
Jake: 对对对
Jake: Yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure:  明天咱们这电视剧被举报了
Shure: Our show might get reported tomorrow.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Jake: 明天可以拍一段警察的镜头哈哈哈
Jake: Tomorrow, we could shoot a scene with the police, haha.
Shure:  邀请邻居
Shure: Invite the neighbors.
Shure:  哎这腰字好难写
Shure: Hey, this "invite" character is hard to write.
Jake: 要不隐外字吧
Jake: How about using the simplified character?
Shure:  我觉得也是
Shure: I think so too.
Tasha: 带上鸡蛋
Tasha: Bring the eggs.
Tasha: 你要是来我就把这一篮送你
Tasha: If you come, I'll give you this whole basket.
Tasha: 你不来就不送
Tasha: If you don't come, no delivery.
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure: 邻
Shure: Neighbor
Shure:  居
Shure: Hood
Shure:  哎这字
Shure: Oh, these words
Shure:  齐白石看着都落泪
Shure: Even Qi Baishi would cry seeing this
Alice: 有种复古的感觉
Alice: It has a retro feel
Shure:  这是我们的plan
Shure: This is our plan
Shure:  存疑plan
Shure: The doubtful plan
Shure:  okay
Shure: Okay
Lucia: 好多问号啊
Lucia: So many question marks
Lucia: 我们好像谜语人
Lucia: We sound like riddlers
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha
Shure: the riddle
Shure: The riddle
Shure:  然后我们还还有
Shure: And then we still have
Shure:  还有什么
Shure: What else do we have?
Jake: 呃这是人员
Jake: Uh, these are the personnel
Shure:  不对
Shure: No, that's not right
Jake: 呃剧组吧剧组还有5个人
Jake: Uh, the crew, right, there are 5 more people in the crew
Jake: 然后就是总共看
Jake: Then we need to look at the total
Jake: 最后我们要host多少个人
Jake: Finally, how many people do we need to host?
Jake: 然后看看这活动在这个人数下
Jake: And then see what we should do with this number
Jake: 应该整点啥
Jake: We should plan something
Jake: 给大家拍
Jake: Let everyone see
Lucia: 这没事没事可以技术处理一下吗
Lucia: It's okay, can we handle this technically?
Jake: 是但是后期给后期很麻烦
Jake: Yes, but it will be a hassle for post-production
Shure: 后期给
Shure: Post-production
Jake:后期很麻烦哈哈
Jake: It's very troublesome, haha
Shure:  添了多少麻烦
Shure: How much trouble did we add?
Shure:  OK所以总共one two three four
Shure: Okay, so in total, one, two, three, four
Lucia: 4到6
Lucia: Four to six
Shure: four加五五个
Shure: Four plus five, that's nine
Shure:  这是9
Shure: This is nine
Jake:4加五九
Jake: Four plus five, nine
Jake: 九九九到11是吧
Jake: Nine, nine, nine to eleven, right?
Jake: 9到11 人
Shure: Nine to eleven people
Jake: 9到11 然后各位自己
Jake: Nine to eleven, then everyone
Shure:  算算上我们是吧
Shure: Including us, right?
Jake:可以 哎就先先先就写到9-11吧
Jake: Okay, let's just write it down as 9-11 for now.
Shure:  9-11
Shure: 9-11.
Shure: 9-11 徒正无穷
Shure: 9-11, an infinite number.
Shure:  因为我们可以邀请邻居
Shure: Because we can invite our neighbors.
Jake: 嗯对对
Jake: Yeah, right, right.
Jake: 非常也有无穷的邻居
Jake: We have countless neighbors too.
Jake: 也不是正无穷吧 16亿
Jake: Well, maybe not infinite, 1.6 billion.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahahaha.
Shure:  现在我们我我国人有16亿了吗
Shure: Do we have 1.6 billion people in our country now?
Jake: 14
Jake: 1.4.
Jake: 1414吧那就14
Jake: 1.4, let's say 1.4.
Shure: 14吧
Shure: 1.4, right?
Shure:  完了这移动的五十万
Shure: Then there's the 500,000 mobile users.
Jake:报数多了
Jake: Overreported.
Jake: 哈哈合适吗
Jake: Hahaha, is that appropriate?
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahahahaha.
Jake: 问题不大问题不大
Jake: It's not a big deal.
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure:  然后好人员确定了
Shure: So, the personnel are confirmed.
Shure:  嗯这是第一
Shure: Yeah, that's the first.
Shure:  第一大点的第三
Shure: The first main point, number three.
Shure:  下面三个小点人员
Shure: The next three sub-points about personnel.
Shure:  然后我们还有第二点
Shure: Then we have the second point.
Shure:  要开始活
Shure: Start the activity.
Shure:  动内容部分吗
Shure: The content part?
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Shure:  这我觉得是一块硬骨头我们要啃很久
Shure: I think this is a tough nut to crack, we'll be working on it for a while.
Shure:  嗯所以我们要直接先来这个吗
Shure: So, should we start with this directly?
Jake: 那还有别的吗
Jake: Is there anything else?
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Shure:  活动内容
Shure: Activity content.
Shure:  大家想想
Shure: Everyone think about it.
Shure:  我记得大家问卷的时候应该是填过的
Shure: I remember you all filled out questionnaires, right?
Shure:  嗯是吧
Shure: Yeah, right?
Jake: 是的
Jake: Yes.
Shure: 大家问卷填的是什么来着
Shure: What did you fill in the questionnaires?
Shure:  不会都是GPT生成的吧
Shure: Hope it wasn't all GPT-generated.
Katrina:  不是哈哈哈我自己写的
Katrina: No, hahaha, I wrote it myself.
Jake: 湖南GPT生成的
Jake: Generated by Hunan GPT
Shure:  那既然提到湖南这笔题那我们先从
Shure: Since we're talking about Hunan, let's start with
Shure:  Loyx同学哈哈哈
Shure: Lyx student
Katrina:  我我想是那个就是呃7天
Katrina: I think it's like, um, 7 days
Katrina:  然后每我买那花嘛
Katrina: Then I bought the flowers, right
Katrina:  然后每人一个花瓶
Katrina: And each person gets a vase
Katrina:  然后就相当于醒花一一到2天
Katrina: So it's like letting the flowers wake up for 1 to 2 days
Katrina:  然后刚好他一个周期
Katrina: Then it just fits a cycle
Katrina:  就是可以让这花慢慢的开放
Katrina: So the flowers can slowly bloom
Katrina:  然后把这个花的花瓣
Katrina: Then we can use the petals
Katrina:  然后做成那种压花
Katrina: To make pressed flowers
Katrina:  然后就比较环保做成那种明信片
Katrina: Which is more eco-friendly, making postcards
Katrina:  还有买了那种亚克力的玻璃
Katrina: And I bought acrylic glass
Katrina:  然后就嵌进去
Katrina: To embed them
Katrina:  就是那种比较好看的手工
Katrina: It's a pretty craft
Katrina:  然后也跟植物有关
Katrina: And it's related to plants
Katrina:  然后原材料又是自己精心养了7天的
Katrina: The raw materials are carefully nurtured by myself for 7 days
Katrina:  然后又觉得形成了一个闭环
Katrina: So I feel like it forms a closed loop
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay
Katrina: 就做了一些周边
Katrina: Made some peripherals
Katrina:  到时候那一天就可以分发给大家
Katrina: On that day, we can distribute them to everyone
Jake: 上才艺
Jake: Show your talent
Katrina:  那花的在哪
Katrina: Where are the flowers?
Alice:在哪
Alice: Where are they?
Katrina:  花还要醒意的
Katrina: The flowers need to wake up
Katrina:  因为我看我
Katrina: Because I think
Katrina:  我刚才想的是种那种什么东西
Katrina: I was just thinking about what kind of thing to plant
Katrina:  符合那种地球世界
Katrina: That fits the Earth Day theme
Katrina:  地球日他7天基本上发不了芽
Katrina: They can't sprout in 7 days
Katrina:  然后我就想是买这种花
Katrina: So I thought of buying these flowers
Jake:上才艺
Jake: Show your talent
Katrina: : 直接那个顺丰发过来
Jake:是这个吗
Jake: Is it this one?
Katrina:  云南的花
Katrina: Flowers from Yunnan
Katrina:  是他好像有两个苞
Lucia: It seems to have two buds
Lucia: 哇，好漂亮
Lucia: Wow, it's so beautiful
Katrina:  对我买了芍药啊
Katrina: Yes, I bought peonies
Shure: 不想送了
Jake: Don't want to give them away anymore
Katrina:  哇
Katrina: Wow
Katrina:  刚好一些花骨朵就这两天就可以开了
Katrina: Some flower buds will bloom in the next couple of days.
Lucia: 要找个剪刀什么的吗
Lucia: Do we need to find some scissors or something?
Alice: 剪刀
Alice: Scissors.
Katrina:  JK Gan吗还是说要把后面的列完
Katrina: JK Gan or should we list the rest?
Jake: 呃先秀一下
Jake: Uh, let's show it first.
Shure: 先秀一下
Shure: Let's show it first.
Alice: 剪刀不见了
Alice: The scissors are missing.
Katrina:  我买了好几束来着
Katrina: I bought several bundles.
Lucia: 嗯哎呀
Lucia: Hmm, oh no.
Shure: 剪刀在这儿呢
Shure: The scissors are here.
Katrina: 还买了康乃馨
Katrina: I also bought some carnations.
Jake:哈哈
Jake: Haha.
Alice: 谢谢
Alice: Thanks.
Katrina:  哈哈谢
Jake: 眼神好啊小伙
Jake: Good eyes, buddy.
Alice: 刚好我们女孩子比较多哈哈
Alice: Just right, we have more girls here, haha.
Katrina:  啊这也是
Katrina: Ah, that's true.
Katrina:  这花瓣就可以做压花
Katrina: These petals can be used for pressed flowers.
Katrina:  然后买了压花器还有那个·干燥剂
Katrina: And then I bought a flower press and some desiccant.
Tasha: 这是什么
Tasha: What's this?
Katrina:  这是花这个要晾一下
Katrina: These are flowers, they need to air dry.
Alice: 这是芍药吗
Alice: Are these peonies?
Katrina:  嗯我买多了我才知道
Katrina: Yeah, I bought too many, I just realized.
Katrina:  他说要一到两天才能开花
Katrina: He said they need one to two days to bloom.
Katrina:  然后想时间就差不多
Katrina: So the timing should be just right.
Katrina:  压花就要压两三天
Katrina: Pressed flowers take two to three days.
Katrina:  然后这个养个两三天
Katrina: And these need two to three days to grow.
Katrina:  这是百合
Katrina: These are lilies.
Alice: 这是香雪蓝还是啥
Alice: Are these freesias or something?
Katrina:  什么百合来着百合蓝
Katrina: Some kind of lily, lily blue.
Tasha: 营养剂泡在水里面加速醒发的
Tasha: Nutrients are soaked in water to speed up the blooming.
Alice: 这两个颜色的
Alice: These two colors.
Katrina:  对一个白一个黄
Katrina: Yeah, one white, one yellow.
Katrina:  是一个包裹
Katrina: It's a package.
Katrina:  我看我记得他好像发两个包裹
Katrina: I remember he sent two packages.
Jake: 要不他上我们也上
Jake: If he goes, we should go too.
Jake: 才艺你看看哪些是你的
Jake: Talent, see which ones are yours.
Tasha: 没有我的
Tasha: None are mine.
Jake: 没有你的啊
Jake: None are yours?
Jake: 你没有买这个
Jake: You didn't buy this?
Jake: 外面的快递就只有雨轩的是吧
Jake: The only package outside is Yuxuan's, right?
Jake: 还有别人买快递
Jake: Did anyone else order something?
Lucia: 你们买东西了吗
Lucia: Did you guys buy anything?
Shure:  还没呢还没
Shure: Not yet, not yet.
Katrina:  还没呢还没
Jake: 行没问题
Jake: Alright, no problem.
Jake: 他刷都是自带的是吧
Jake: Does he come with his own gear?
Shure:  带资进组
Shure: He joins the group with funding.
Shure:  你看这就
Shure: You see, this is...
Jake:确实
Jake: Indeed.
Shure: 觉悟
Boss: Enlightenment.
Katrina:  然后呢
Katrina: And then...
Lucia: 花瓶
Lucia: A vase.
Jake: 比划比划
Jake: Gesture, gesture.
Jake: 就是大概要个什么形式
Jake: So, what kind of style are we looking for?
Katrina: 形式吗 形式就是我们6个人一人一个花瓶
Katrina: Style? The style is that each of the six of us gets a vase.
Katrina:  花瓶我也买好了
Katrina: I've already bought the vases.
Katrina:  然后大家把这花分分分分了以后养了
Katrina: Then everyone will distribute the flowers, take care of them...
Katrina:  一一一到两三天
Katrina: For about one to two or three days...
Katrina:  呃他这个就会慢慢全部开了嘛
Katrina: Uh, they will slowly start to bloom.
Katrina:  开了以后就用这种花瓣或者是
Katrina: After opening it, use these petals or...
Katrina:  我看他们压花
Katrina: I saw them pressing flowers.
Katrina:  就是直接把这个花骨朵花剪下来
Katrina: Just cut off the flower bud directly.
Katrina:  然后就直接这样压
Katrina: Then press it like this.
Katrina:  他就会变成一个那种平面的
Katrina: It'll turn into a flat, opened flower.
Katrina:  然后展开的那个花
Katrina: Then you can put it on a postcard.
Katrina:  然后就可以坐在那种明信片
Katrina: I bought those postcard greeting cards.
Katrina:  我买的那种明信片贺卡
Katrina: And also, what's it called...
Katrina:  还有那个包括那个叫什么
Katrina: Those acrylic double-layer glass frames.
Katrina:  那种亚克力双层玻璃
Katrina: Like a picture frame, you can...
Katrina:  然后像像一个那种相框就可以
Katrina: Give it to others, with some leaves and stuff.
Katrina:  送给别人然后一些叶子啊什么的
Katrina: So I was thinking...
Katrina:  然后当时想的是
Katrina: You have those outdoor activities, right?
Katrina:  你不是有那个户外活动吗
Katrina: We can collect some leaves.
Katrina:  我们就可以去捡一些叶子
Katrina: And put them together into a picture.
Katrina:  然后就把它拼成一幅画一样的
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: And also bookmarks, everyone makes them for fun.
Katrina:  然后书签也有然后就大家自己做着玩
Katrina: And on the last day...
Katrina:  然后最后一天
Katrina:  因为想这种形式
Katrina:  这种就邀请什么各种好朋友啊什么的
Katrina: You know, inviting all sorts of friends and stuff.
Katrina:  就可以你自己做的自己养的
Katrina: You can make it yourself and raise it yourself.
Katrina:  然后分发给大家就挺好
Katrina: And then share it with everyone, which is pretty nice.
Katrina:  然后也比较符合7天这个周期嘛
Katrina: Plus, it fits well with the 7-day cycle.
Alice: 嗯要不先给他醒了吧
Alice: Hmm, why don't we wake him up first?
Katrina:  嗯可以啊今天我肯今天是一定要把它醒了
Katrina: Yeah, sure, today I definitely want to wake him up.
Jake: 先聊吧这个回头下一个
Shure: Let's chat first, we'll do the next one later.
Katrina:  行下一个下一个谁
Katrina: Alright, who's next?
Katrina:  下一个我来弄这个
Katrina: I'll handle the next one.
Katrina:  下一个谁来
Katrina: Who's next?
Shure: 下一个 路路亚同学啊
Shure: Next up, Lulua.
Katrina:  啊，我来
Katrina: Ah, I'll do it.
Shure: 露西
Shure: Lucia.
Lucia: 啊其实就是我的构思
Lucia: Ah, actually it's my idea.
Lucia: 也跟DIY是有关系的
Lucia: It's also related to DIY.
Lucia: 对我刚我刚开始想的是
Lucia: So, what I initially thought was,
Lucia: 就是可以因为是世界地球日
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day,
Lucia: 所以我想就是做一点环保一点的东西
Lucia: I wanted to make something more eco-friendly.
Lucia: 就我不知道大家有没有做过水母灯
Lucia: I don't know if anyone has made a jellyfish lamp before.
Lucia: 就这两年在景区还挺火的
Lucia: It's been quite popular at scenic spots these past two years.
Lucia: 呃就是长得像水母一样的一个小灯
Lucia: It's a small lamp that looks like a jellyfish.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Right.
Lucia: 然后这个东西它原本是有材料包的
Lucia: And it comes with a materials kit originally.
Lucia: 就是可以直接在网上买材料包做
Lucia: You can buy the kit online and make it.
Lucia: 但是我就是我想的是
Lucia: But what I was thinking was,
Lucia: 就是既然是世界地球日的话
Lucia: Since it's Earth Day,
Lucia: 我之前在网上刷到过一个教程
Lucia: I saw a tutorial online before,
Lucia: 就是可以用那个奶茶杯盖
Lucia: You can use a milk tea cup lid
Lucia: 然后以它作为一个主体
Lucia: as the main body.
Lucia: 然后就是再加一些丝带
Lucia: Then add some ribbons
Lucia: 或者串珠之类的
Lucia: or beads or something.
Lucia: 呃我不知道咱们这有没有热热胶枪
Lucia: I don't know if we have a hot glue gun here.
Lucia: 如果没有的话
Lucia: If not,
Lucia: 可以后面看有没有什么替代的
Lucia: we can see if there's an alternative.
Lucia: 或者说买一个也行
Lucia: Or we could just buy one.
Lucia: 然后就是大家一起
Lucia: Then everyone can,
Lucia: 就是每个人都做一个这样的小灯
Lucia: make their own little lamp.
Lucia: 就是它还挺好看的
Lucia: They look pretty nice.
Lucia: 然后这是其中一个设想
Lucia: So, that's one of the ideas.
Lucia: 还有一个就是也是
Lucia: And there's also
Lucia: 有点这种怎么说呢
Lucia: A bit of, how do I say
Lucia: 低碳和循环利用的
Lucia: Low-carbon and recycling
Lucia: 就是大家有没有做过纸箱小狗
Lucia: Have you guys ever made a cardboard dog?
Lucia: 就前段时间特别火那个啊
Lucia: It was really popular recently
Katrina:  可以放在那个
Katrina: You can put it
Lucia: 对然后可以放在门口
Lucia: Yeah, you can put it at the door
Lucia: 然后纸箱小狗的好处就是
Lucia: The good thing about a cardboard dog is
Lucia: 如果想要很简单做一下的话
Lucia: If you want to make it simple
Lucia: 就拿纸箱简单剪一下
Lucia: Just cut the cardboard a bit
Lucia: 然后画一个小狗头粘上就可以
Lucia: And draw a dog’s head and stick it on
Lucia: 如果想要复杂一点的话
Lucia: If you want it more complicated
Lucia: 就是也有一些
Lucia: Then there are some
Lucia: 就是复杂点就需要多剪几个
Lucia: More complicated ones where you need to cut more pieces
Lucia: 然后做成一个大的
Lucia: And make a bigger one
Lucia: 我之前看到有人做过杜宾
Lucia: I saw someone make a Doberman
Lucia: 但是那个我没做过就是
Lucia: But I haven't made that one
Lucia: 但是就是看了一下教程
Lucia: But I looked at the tutorial
Lucia: 好像也挺简单的
Lucia: It seems pretty simple
Lucia: 只要画一下卡纸就能很容易剪出来
Lucia: Just draw on the cardboard and cut it out easily
Shure:  咱们最不缺的就是纸箱
Shure: We have no shortage of cardboard
Shure:  所以我觉得这个
Shure: So I think this
Lucia: 对我当时想的也是
Lucia: Yeah, that's what I thought too
Lucia: 在咱们这里到时候肯定会有很多纸箱
Lucia: We'll definitely have a lot of cardboard here
Lucia: 如果说就能直接使用的话
Lucia: If we can use it directly
Lucia: 就还挺环保的
Lucia: It's pretty eco-friendly
Lucia: 就也很契合世界地球日这个主题
Lucia: And it fits the Earth Day theme well
Jake: 对
Jake: Yes
Shure: start
Shure: Start
Lucia: 然后最后还有一个想法
Lucia: And lastly, one more idea
Lucia: 但是这个想法实施起来就比较困难
Lucia: But this idea is harder to implement
Lucia: 我本来想的是
Lucia: I was thinking
Lucia: 可能大家可以简单的排一个小短剧
Lucia: Maybe everyone can put together a short play
Lucia: 或者之类的
Lucia: Or something like that
Lucia: 对因为我之前跟我小伙伴有说
Lucia: Because I talked to my friend before
Lucia: 我们今天拍一些微电影这种
Lucia: We filmed some micro-movies today
Lucia: 但是如果要排一个小短剧的话
Lucia: But if we want to put on a short play
Lucia: 就是我现在暂时还没有想到一个现成
Lucia: I haven't thought of a ready-made script yet
Lucia: 我们目前就拿来用的剧本
Lucia: That we can use right now
Lucia: 因为咱们时间比较短
Lucia: Because our time is quite short
Lucia: 就如果要现在去编的话
Lucia: If we were to write it now,
Lucia: 可能就不太来得及
Lucia: it might be too late.
Lucia: 就如果大家有想到什么
Lucia: If anyone thinks of something,
Lucia: 你们以前看到过的短视频之类的
Lucia: like short videos you've seen before,
Lucia: 这种也可以
Lucia: those could work too.
Lucia: 就如果有个现成的剧本
Lucia: If we have a ready script,
Lucia: 我觉得咱们可以尝试拍一下对
Lucia: I think we can try filming it.
Shure:  OK 好
Shure: OK, got it.
Lucia: 这个是目前暂时的想法
Lucia: This is the current idea for now.
Shure:  这是Lucia
Shure: This is Lucia.
Shure:  这是
Shure: This is...
Shure:  露西亚哈哈
Shure: Luci-ah, haha.
Lucia: 哦我们两个名字好像
Lucia: Oh, our names sound similar.
Lucia: 真的哎
Lucia: Really, huh?
Alice: 你把他名写反了哎
Alice: You wrote his name backwards.
Lucia: 哎，人家是lyx哈哈哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hey, his name is lyx, haha.
Alice: 直接加一道就行
Alice: Just add a stroke and it's fine.
Jake: 哈哈哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina:  完了就是那个变异xy染色体的
Katrina: So, the mutated XY chromosome one.
Jake: 对对对变异
Jake: Yes, yes, mutated.
Shure:  好家伙这俩你都有
Shure: Wow, you have both?
Shure:  是吗哈哈哈哈
Shure: Really? Hahaha.
Shure:  趴下
Shure: Get down.
Tasha: OK上我的道具拿出来哈哈哈哈
Tasha: OK, I'll get my prop out, haha.
Jake: 哈哈上道具BGM
Jake: Haha, bring out the prop BGM.
Shure:  当当当当当当当
Shure: Dun dun dun dun dun dun dun.
Lucia:此处应有有背景音乐哈哈
Lucia: There should be background music here, haha.
Shure:  他的道具为什么在你的行李箱里
Shure: Why is his prop in your suitcase?
Jake: 啊因为又是代言人
Jake: Oh, because he's the spokesperson again.
Tasha: 就这个啊
Tasha: Just this one.
Tasha: 啊你怎么没拆
Tasha: Oh, why didn't you open it?
Tasha: 我去拿个现成的吧
Tasha: I'll go get a ready one.
Tasha: 你把培养皿拿出来吧
Tasha: You take out the Petri dish.
Shure:  培养皿
Shure: Petri dish.
Jake:培养皿
Jake: Petri dish.
Jake: 培养米买了
Jake: Petri dish bought.
Jake: 但是不一定到了
Jake: But it may not have arrived yet.
Jake: 不一定到哈
Jake: Not necessarily.
Jake: 我看一下
Jake: Let me check.
Katrina:  买了康乃馨
Katrina: I bought carnations.
Katrina:  这个叫叫叫
Katrina: This one's called...
Katrina:  芍药康乃馨
Katrina: Peony carnations.
Katrina:  直播间买的
Katrina: Bought it during a livestream.
Lucia: 哈哈好好看呀
Lucia: Haha, it looks so pretty.
Katrina:  直播间买
Katrina: Bought it during a livestream.
Katrina:  顺丰秒送
Katrina: Express delivery.
Katrina:  哎他昨天花瓶昨天也到了
Katrina: Oh, the vase also arrived yesterday.
Jake: 对到了
Jake: Yes, it arrived.
Katrina:  这都是我们的快递
Katrina: These are all our packages.
Jake:对
Jake: Yes.
Tasha: 好像没有别的种类
Tasha: Seems like there are no other types.
Katrina:  可以装在这种里面
Katrina: You can put it in this.
Katrina:  我看一下
Katrina: Let me see.
Katrina:  弄出来特别漂亮
Katrina: It looks really pretty when done.
Shure:  你这是相框
Shure: Is this a photo frame?
Katrina:  对就把花夹在里面
Katrina: Yes, just press the flowers inside.
Katrina:  还有一些叶子什么的可以摆在家里
Katrina: And some leaves, you can display it at home.
Katrina:  这确实这怎么雾蒙蒙的
Katrina: Actually, why does it look so foggy?
Katrina:  他中间应该夹了一层东西
Katrina: There must be a layer of something in the middle.
Jake: 被嫌弃了
Jake: Feeling rejected.
Jake: 我应该拆吗
Jake: Should I open it?
Tasha: 然后哈哈
Tasha: And then haha.
Tasha: 就是这是
Tasha: This is...
Tasha: 自己设计的一些种子纸
Tasha: Some seed paper that I designed.
Lucia: 哇，好厉害
Lucia: Wow, amazing.
Tasha: 就是把种子放在这个纸里面
Tasha: You put the seeds in the paper.
Tasha: 这个纸是用废弃的咖啡渣
Tasha: The paper is made from discarded coffee grounds.
Tasha: 呃一些纸
Tasha: And some paper.
Tasha: 然后做成那种纸浆
Tasha: Then you make it into a pulp.
Tasha: 然后纸浆里面有那种乳种子
Tasha: The pulp contains the seeds.
Tasha: 都是用的太阳花种子
Tasha: They are sunflower seeds.
Tasha: 太阳花种子它比较容易发芽
Tasha: Sunflower seeds are easier to sprout.
Tasha: 然后如果用培养皿水培的话
Tasha: If you use a petri dish and water,
Tasha: 大概5天左右就可以发芽
Tasha: they can sprout in about 5 days.
Tasha: 然后做了一些种类的
Tasha: And I made a few types.
Tasha: 算世界地球日吗
Tasha: Does this count for Earth Day?
Jake: 那可地球了
Jake: That’s incredible.
Alice: 这是你自己做的吗
Alice: Did you make this yourself?
Lucia: 哇好厉害
Lucia: Wow, that's amazing.
Katrina: 嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Tasha: 然后做了5种
Tasha: And then I made five types.
Tasha: 地球的
Tasha: Earth-themed ones.
Tasha: 然后做了两种很简单的
Tasha: And then I made two simpler ones.
Tasha: 哈哈但是你是原创哎
Tasha: Haha, but you created the original design!
Jake: 有点强
Jake: That’s pretty strong.
Tasha: 对
Tasha: Yes.
Jake: 种子片
Jake: Seed cards.
Jake: 种子片嗯
Jake: Seed cards, hmm.
Shure:  种子片
Shure: Seed cards.
Tasha: 嗯然后这样就比较环保
Tasha: Yeah, and this way it’s more environmentally friendly.
Lucia: 嗯真的很环保
Lucia: Hmm, it’s really eco-friendly.
Katrina:  真的很环保
Katrina: Really eco-friendly.
Katrina:  而且还极具美感好吗
Katrina: And it’s also very aesthetically pleasing, right?
Katrina:  1234 好
Katrina: 1234, okay.
Jake: 那你自己设计的
Jake: So you designed it yourself?
Alice:嗯对我也去拿一下我的东西
Alice: Yeah, I’ll go get my stuff too.
Jake: 是画的图吗
Jake: Did you draw the pictures?
Tasha: 啊这很简单了
Tasha: Ah, this is simple.
Tasha: 就找一些logo
Tasha: Just find some logos.
Tasha: 然后这个logo一找
Tasha: And once you find the logo,
Tasha: 写个字框个框就行了
Tasha: just write some words and frame it.
Tasha: OK
Tasha: OK.
Jake: 挺好的挺好
Jake: Pretty good, pretty good.
Lucia: 好厉害
Lucia: So impressive.
Katrina:  种子卡片
Katrina: Seed cards.
Katrina:  然后呢就是
Katrina: And then, um,
Alice: 嗯买了一个拼图
Alice: Hmm, I bought a puzzle.
Alice: 是一个呃大底层是一个圆的
Alice: It’s a, uh, the base layer is round.
Alice: 然后它那个里面是这种的
Alice: And inside, it has these.
Alice: 就是各种动物的那种
Alice: It’s all kinds of animals.
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh.
Alice:然后你看你能不能
Alice: And then you see if you can
Alice: 就是一个比较难的一个拼图
Alice: It's a pretty difficult puzzle
Alice: 然后有很多种动物
Alice: With lots of different animals
Alice: 我想的就是呃你去尽力的往里面拼
Alice: What I think is, uh, you try your best to fit them in
Alice: 就是我觉得这个拼图就给人一种
Alice: I feel like this puzzle gives a sense of
Alice: 我们在地球上
Alice: Us on Earth
Alice: 可以和谐共处的那个感觉
Alice: Living harmoniously together
Alice: 然后你不一定全都能拼上
Alice: And you might not be able to fit everything
Alice: 但是因为这种不是那个严丝合缝
Alice: But since it's not perfectly seamless
Alice: 不是特别完全严丝合缝
Alice: It's not completely seamless
Alice: 就是说你可以拼多一点
Alice: It means you can fit more
Alice: 也可以拼少一点
Alice: Or you can fit less
Alice: 然后我就想
Alice: And then I thought
Alice: 呃可能就是一个小的游戏吧
Alice: Uh, maybe it's just a little game
Jake: 头头发
Jake: Hair, hair
Jake: 呵呵呵
Jake: Hehehe
Alice:对
Alice: Yeah
Jake:要不
Jake: Or else
Jake: 要不夹进去
Jake: Or else clip it
Katrina:  有没有夹子
Katrina: Do we have a clip?
Jake:好
Jake: Okay
Alice: 然后就是
Shure: And then
Alice: 我就想给参与者就是一个小奖品
Alice: I wanted to give the participants a small prize
Alice: 就是一颗水仙种球
Alice: It's a daffodil bulb
Alice: 因为这个水仙种球它好养
Alice: Because this daffodil bulb is easy to take care of
Alice: 就是呃
Alice: Like, uh
Alice: 在我的那种植物杀手朋友身上
Alice: I've tested it on my friends who are plant killers
Alice: 试验过了
Alice: They could keep it alive
Alice: 他都能养活的东西
Alice: And it blooms beautifully
Alice: 然后这个花开出来也特别的好看
Alice: It also has a pleasant fragrance
Alice: 然后还有清香的味道
Alice: And as you watch it grow day by day
Alice: 并且你看着他一天天长大
Alice: You get that feeling of participating in nature
Alice: 你很有那种参与自然的感觉
Alice: Yeah, so that's my idea
Alice: 对所以这就是我的想法
Alice: But I haven't bought the daffodil bulbs yet
Alice: 但是水仙球还没买
Alice: But I know
Alice: 但是我有
Alice: I know a place that sells really good ones
Alice: 我知道有一家质量特别好的
Alice: I've grown them myself
Alice: 我养过的就是
Alice: They're just
Alice: 有需要他可以直接买过来
Alice: If needed, he can just buy it.
Jake: 好
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 仙球
Jake: Nice shot.
Shure:  活动内容现在有4个
Shure: There are four activities now.
Shure:  到谁了
Shure: Whose turn is it?
Alice: 我写吧
Tasha: I'll write it.
Tasha: 不是到我了吗
Tasha: Isn't it my turn?
Shure:  野生动物拼图
Shure: Wildlife puzzle.
Katrina:  哎我还想让我第一天吃海底捞
Katrina: Oh, I was hoping to have Haidilao on the first day.
Katrina:  送了我一个种草莓的那个盆栽
Katrina: They gave me a strawberry planting pot.
Katrina:  也可以种一下海底捞那那个豌豆
Katrina: We could also plant the peas from Haidilao.
Jake:海底捞
Jake: Haidilao.
Tasha: 那那个豌豆还可以种
Tasha: Those peas can be planted too.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Yeah.
Katrina:  对还可以种啊
Katrina: Yeah, they can be planted.
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah.
Katrina:  海底捞就最近不是跟樱桃小丸子联名
Katrina: Recently, Haidilao has a collaboration with Chibi Maruko-chan.
Katrina:  点他那个东西他就送你那个盆栽
Katrina: Click on that thing and he’ll give you that bonsai.
Katrina:  哦这么好
Katrina: Oh, that's so nice.
Lucia: 哦这么好
Katrina:  我说他咋知道我要过来种东西
Katrina: I was wondering how he knew I was coming to plant stuff.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahahahaha
Katrina:  想盆栽要一个月才能发芽
Katrina: I thought it would take a month for the plant to sprout.
Jake: 走上海边种树去
Jake: Let's go to the beach and plant trees.
Shure:  然后到我了
Shure: Then it's my turn.
Jake:到您了
Jake: It's your turn.
Shure:  我的是一个啧
Shure: I have a...
Shure:  一个类似于二手拍卖的
Shure: It's kind of like a second-hand auction.
Shure:  一个一个一个一个一个一个一个想法
Shure: One idea, one idea, one idea, one idea...
Jake: OK
Jake: OK.
Shure: 我不知道
Shure: I don't know.
Shure:  大家平时会不会去一些什么
Shure: Do you guys usually go to any...
Shure:  比如说小小小酒馆啊
Shure: Like, small pubs or...
Shure:  或者是咖啡店
Shure: Coffee shops?
Shure:  就那种比较有烟火气的地方
Shure: You know, places with a lot of life and atmosphere?
Shure:  然后之前那个
Shure: And then that time...
Shure:  北京有一个连锁的精酿啤酒
Shure: There's a chain of craft beer places in Beijing.
Shure:  叫跳海
Shure: It's called jumping into the sea
Katrina: 哦我知道在什刹海那是不是
Katrina: Oh, I know it's at Shichahai, right?
Shure:  对什刹海应该是这个吧
Shure: Yes, Shichahai, I think so
Jake: 然后指的是这个吗
Jake: And does it mean this?
Shure:  其其他城市也有
Shure: Other cities have it too
Shure:  什么市场也有
Shure: Some markets have it too
Shure:  然后他们前两天大榕寺开业的时候
Shure: Then, a couple of days ago, when the Big Banyan Temple opened
Shure:  他们搞了一个
Shure: They did something
Shure:  就是类似于这个拍卖的
Shure: Like an auction
Shure:  一个一个一个形式吧
Shure: A kind of format
Shure:  然后就是
Shure: And then
Shure:  嗯
Shure: Um
Shure:  他们当时是你喝酒会给你一个币
Shure: They gave you a token if you drank alcohol
Jake: 知道吗
Jake: You know?
Shure: 然后用这个币
Shure: And then with that token
Shure:  来买大家的一些任何的东西
Shure: You could buy anything from everyone
Shure:  可以是一个是是一个诗集
Shure: It could be a collection of poems
Shure:  可以是一个故事
Shure: It could be a story
Shure:  然后也可以是一个
Shure: Or it could be
Shure:  就是真实存在的一个物品
Shure: A real physical item
Shure:  然后就每人
Shure: And then everyone
Shure:  就是那个每个物品都做一个小的PPT
Shure: Everyone made a small PPT for each item
Shure:  然后展示出来
Shure: And displayed it
Katrina: 啊还要做ppt吗
Katrina: Ah, you need to make a PPT?
Shure:  然后然后然后哈哈哈哈
Shure: And then, and then, hahaha
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Lucia: 这是工作狂游戏吗
Lucia: Is this a workaholic game?
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Lucia: Hahaha
Shure: 啊不然后然
Shure: Ah no, then
Shure:  后然后
Shure: Then
Shure:  然后然后
Shure: And then
Shure:  然后就是一个拍卖吧
Shure: It was like an auction
Shure:  然后我们可以怎么样呢
Shure: And we could do what?
Shure:  就是来的这些嘉宾
Shure: The guests who came
Shure:  然后大家一人分享一个故事
Shure: Each person shared a story
Shure:  或者是呃
Shure: Or, uh
Shure:  事故也好
Shure: An incident or something
Shure:  故事也好
Shure: The story is good.
Shure:  然后来我们给评定
Shure: Then we'll give it a rating.
Shure:  觉得这个故事怎么样
Shure: What do you think of the story?
Jake: 值多少个币是吧
Jake: How many coins is it worth?
Shure:  对值多少个币
Shure: Yes, how many coins is it worth?
Shure:  然后给他
Shure: And then we give him
Shure:  然后这个币就
Shure: and then these coins...
Tasha: 像什么
Tasha: Like what?
Tasha: 一个故事换一根藤条的那种
Tasha: Like trading a story for a stick or something?
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure:  哦对
Shure: Oh, right.
Shure: 对
Shure: Yeah.
Shure:  然后这个币就用来拍卖
Shure: And then these coins are used for auctioning.
Shure:  接下来这些嘉宾带来的二手物品
Shure: Next, the guests bring their second-hand items.
Shure:  以及是我们就是闲置的一些二手物品
Shure: And also some of the unused second-hand items we have.
Shure:  然后来进行这样的一个交换
Shure: Then we can do this kind of exchange.
Shure:  就是
Shure: It's...
Shure:  也是跟这个环保理念比较比较挂钩的
Shure: also quite in line with the environmental protection concept.
Shure:  行大概就是这个样子
Shure: So, it's basically like this.
Katrina:  就是讲故事
Katrina: So, telling stories...
Katrina:  换了币然后就可以购买
Katrina: exchanges coins, and then you can buy...
Katrina:  购买他们自己带来的闲置物品嘛
Katrina: buy the unused items they bring, right?
Shure:  每个人拍
Shure: Each person auctions...
Shure:  拍卖就是比如说我
Shure: like, for example, I...
Shure:  我要卖一个什么东西
Shure: I want to sell something.
Shure:  然后我上来讲一下这个东西
Shure: Then I come up and talk about this item.
Shure:  然后我认为他的起拍价大概多少
Shure: Then I estimate its starting price.
Shure:  然后拍到这个钱
Shure: Then the money from the auction...
Shure:  是给到那个拍卖的那个人的
Shure: goes to the person who auctioned it.
Shure:  然后他也流通过去那个货币
Shure: Then the currency circulates.
Shure:  然后我拿着这些货币
Shure: And then I take these coins...
Shure:  我可以再去拍卖
Shure: and I can auction again.
Katrina:  你再去买别的
Shure: You can buy something else.
Shure:  对剩下的
Shure: Yes, the remaining items.
Lucia: 啊，好有创意耶
Lucia: Wow, that's so creative!
Alice: 反正就是换了一种交流的货币
Alice: Anyway, it's just exchanging a different kind of currency.
Alice: 哈哈哈
Alice: Hahaha.
Katrina:  也构建了我们整个的经济体系
Katrina: It also builds our entire economic system.
Katrina:  哈哈哈货币流通
Katrina: Hahaha, currency circulation.
Tasha: OK那我就看他这个行
Tasha: OK, I'll see if this works.
Katrina: 我们都是那个市场的内部了
Katrina: We're all part of that market.
Shure:  啊对可以把
Shure: Ah yes, we can.
Shure:  对可以把
Katrina: 我们都是我们都是搞
Katrina: We're all doing this.
Katrina:  我们都是搞赚币的
Tasha: Making money.
Katrina:  他是他是搞货币流通的
Katrina: He's into currency circulation.
Lucia: 可以做一些手工艺品
Lucia: We can make some crafts.
Lucia: 用来用来拍卖
Lucia: For auctioning.
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah.
Lucia: 对可以啊
Lucia: Yeah, we can.
Katrina:  就我们做这个
Katrina: We can do this.
Jake: 就我们平台方做这个
Jake: Our platform can do this.
Katrina:  也可以
Katrina: That works too.
Jake:平台方和小店
Jake: Platform side and small shop...
Jake: 小店家对
Jake: Small shops, right.
Katrina: 对哈哈哈哈
Katrina: Yeah, hahaha.
Shure:  今天就是这样的形式
Shure: That's how it is today.
Tasha: 这是我的商品
Tasha: This is my product.
Tasha: 我要拍卖的
Tasha: I'm going to auction it.
Katrina:  哈哈哈
Katrina: Hahaha.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Shure:  还有什么想法吗
Shure: Any other ideas?
Shure:  大家
Shure: Anyone?
Katrina: 我看看啊
Katrina: Let me think...
Katrina:  在那一天邀请他
Katrina: Invite them that day.
Katrina:  们过来这是我们准备的一些嗯东东西
Katrina: This is some stuff we prepared, um...
Katrina:  那怎么招待他们要不要搞一点什么
Katrina: How should we entertain them? Should we do something?
Katrina:  就像我我我经常我们学校草坪发
Katrina: Like, often at our school's lawn...
Katrina:  他们会自己调酒
Katrina: They make their own drinks.
Katrina:  就自己自己
Katrina: Just on their own...
Katrina:  人多的时候就有点像那种小party一样
Katrina: When there are lots of people, it feels like a little party.
Katrina: 可以在外面
Katrina: We can do it outside.
Shure:  啊我可以可以给大家冲咖啡
Shure: Ah, I can make coffee for everyone.
Shure:  我那有有一套手冲的东西
Shure: I have a set of tools for hand-brewed coffee.
Tasha: 哈哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Katrina:  对就是可以请大家喝点东西
Katrina: Yeah, we can treat everyone to some drinks.
Shure:  笑的这么开心
Shure: You're laughing so happily.
Jake: 突然开心了起来
Jake: Suddenly feeling happy, huh?
Lucia: 支持
Lucia: I support it.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Katrina: 就表演
Katrina: Just perform.
Shure: c加a coffee and alcohol
Shure: C plus A, coffee and alcohol.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Hmm.
Shure: 可以吧
Shure: Is that alright?
Katrina:  对那就是整个活动
Katrina: Yeah, that should cover the whole event.
Katrina:  那一天大概持续多长时间
Katrina: How long will the event last that day?
Jake: 一下午呗
Jake: The whole afternoon.
Katrina:  一下午
Katrina: The whole afternoon.
Katrina:  嗯那就给他们提供一些饮品就够了吧
Katrina: Hmm, then just providing them with some drinks should be enough, right?
Shure:  对
Shure: Yeah.
Katrina:  对先饮品然后我们就有点像
Katrina: Right, drinks first, then we kind of...
Katrina: 先饮品然后我们就有点像
Katrina: Drinks first, then we kind of...
Katrina:  这这算市级部分
Katrina: This counts as the city-level part.
Katrina:  然后饮品部分也有了
Katrina: And then we have the drinks part covered too.
Katrina:  那是不是还要什么节目啊您之前
Katrina: So do we still need some programs? You mentioned before...
Jake: 嗯对可以
Jake: Hmm, yeah, we can.
Jake: 嗯或者最后一天应该是从中午
Jake: Hmm, or the last day should start from noon.
Jake: 中午管不管饭
Jake: Are we providing lunch?
Jake: 这个另说
Jake: That's another matter.
Jake: 也可以管也可以不管共多少个人
Jake: We can provide lunch or not, depending on how many people there are.
Katrina:  好像
Katrina: Seems like...
Katrina:  不用管饭但是可以请他做一点点甜的
Katrina: We don't need to provide lunch, but we can offer some sweets.
Jake: 对对对下午茶
Jake: Yeah, yeah, afternoon tea.
Katrina:  对
Katrina: Right.
Jake:嗯对那就是不用管饭
Jake: Hmm, yeah, so no need for lunch.
Jake: 大家吃完饭过来
Jake: Everyone can come after lunch.
Jake: 然后时间线我们捏一下
Jake: And then we can adjust the timeline a bit.
Jake: 如果是下午开始两点比如说或者3点
Jake: If we start in the afternoon, let's say at 2 PM or 3 PM.
Jake: 3点一直干到晚上之类的
Jake: We can go until the evening or so.
Katrina:  可以干到晚上但是天气怎么样
Katrina: We can go until the evening, but how's the weather going to be?
Jake: 这个就不知道了
Jake: That, we don't know yet.
Katrina: 我看会不会下雨
Katrina: I'll see if it's going to rain.
Katrina:  不下雨的话如果像今天这种天的话
Katrina: If it doesn't rain and the weather is like today,
Katrina:  弄到晚上还是挺漂亮的
Katrina: It will look really nice in the evening.
Jake:嗯
Jake: Yeah.
Jake: 对今天下午的话
Jake: This afternoon,
Jake: 这个小院子应该也挺舒服的
Jake: This little yard should be quite comfortable.
Jake: 你还还可以烧烤
Jake: You can even have a barbecue.
Katrina:  嗯
Katrina: Yeah.
Jake: 买签了吗
Jake: Did you buy the skewers?
Shure:  还没呢
Shure: Not yet.
Jake:好
Jake: Alright.
Shure: 我今天一起购入
Shure: I'll buy them together today.
Jake:好的
Jake: Okay.
Jake: 还要买碳的
Jake: We also need to buy charcoal.
Shure: 签碳肉这些
Shure: Skewers, charcoal, meat, all that stuff.
Shure:  其实就是外卖都有其实可以当日达的
Shure: Actually, we can just order it for same-day delivery.
Jake: 行行
Jake: Sure, sure.
Katrina:  21号
Katrina: On the 21st.
Shure:  大家平时厨艺如何
Shure: How's everyone's cooking skills usually?
Shure:  就是会使用刀吗
Shure: Like, can you handle a knife?
Jake:哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha.
Katrina: 会啊
Katrina: Yeah, I can.
Tasha: 我还行呵呵
Tasha: I'm okay, haha.
Lucia: 会还是会的
Lucia: Yeah, I can use one.
Jake: 会比较会使用
Jake: I'm pretty good with it.
Shure:  能切个肉什么的吗
Shure: Can you cut meat and stuff?
修老板: 能切都能切吧
Jack: Everyone can cut, right?
Jake: 都能切
Jake: Yeah, we can all cut.
Shure: OK
Shure: OK.
Jake:各位都能切了
Jake: Everyone can cut.
Shure:  有大家这句话我就放心了
Shure: Hearing that makes me feel relieved.
Jake: 因为你不切
Jake: Because you won't be cutting.
Lucia: 那个肉稍微冷藏一下
Lucia: Chill the meat a bit.
Lucia: 然后拿出来稍微放一会的时候好切
Lucia: Then take it out and let it sit for a while, it'll be easier to cut.
Lucia: 嗯如果是软的肉我不是很会切
Lucia: If the meat is too soft, I can't cut it well.
Lucia: 就已经化好的那种
Lucia: Like if it's already thawed.
Shure: 明白
Shure: Got it.
Shure: 行
Shure: Okay.
Jake: 行可以烤是吧
Jake: So we can grill it, right?
Shure:  可以烤
Shure: Yeah, we can grill it.
Shure: 长春烤串
Jake: Changchun BBQ
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha
Katrina:  其实调酒好像就是买买一点那种
Katrina: Actually, for mixing drinks, you just need to buy a little bit of that stuff
Shure: 啤酒
Shure: Beer
Katrina:  对然后搞一点冰块
Katrina: Yeah, and then get some ice cubes
Shure:  对
Shure: Right
Shure:  冰块的话
Shure: As for ice cubes
Katrina:  哎我现在前面我们走两步
Katrina: Hey, let's walk a bit further up
Katrina:  不是有个咖啡厅
Katrina: Isn't there a café?
Katrina:  能不能问他们借点冰块
Katrina: Can we ask them to lend us some ice cubes?
Katrina:  就不用自己买制冰机了
Katrina: So we don't need to buy an ice machine ourselves
Shure:  可以
Shure: Sure
Katrina: 我们花钱买点冰块
Katrina: We'll pay for the ice cubes
Shure:  那边有咖啡厅吗
Shure: Is there a café over there?
Katrina:  对啊昨天停车那位置
Katrina: Yeah, where we parked yesterday
Lucia: 如果我们要求不那么高的话
Lucia: If we don't have high demands
Lucia: 就是买一个冰膜然后自己冻一下
Lucia: We can just buy an ice mold and freeze it ourselves
Lucia: 也可以啊
Lucia: That works too
Katrina: 啊
Katrina: Ah
Lucia: 只不过就是冻出来可能没有
Lucia: It just might not be as clear as
Katrina:  哎我们有透明
Katrina: Hey, we have a transparent one
Lucia: 咖啡厅那么有透明
Katrina:  我们有冰箱
Katrina: We have a fridge
Katrina:  就买个那个模具倒点水
Katrina: Just buy a mold and pour some water
Katrina:  前天晚上冻一下
Katrina: Freeze it overnight
Alice: 用蒸馏水就行
Alice: Use distilled water
Lucia: 哦
Lucia: Oh
Alice:就煮过煮沸的水
Alice: Just boil the water first
Lucia: 哦可以
Lucia: Oh, that works
Shure:  蒸馏水对
Shure: Distilled water, right
Shure:  可还行呵呵呵
Shure: That could work, haha
Shure:  我们到底是在搞什么
Shure: What exactly are we doing here?
Shure:  搞实验了是吗
Shure: Are we doing an experiment?
Katrina:  那他整整体的时间流程呢
Katrina: So, what's the overall schedule?
Jake: 比如说我们从入场3点3点开始吧
Jake: Let's say we start at 3 PM, from entering the venue
Katrina:  几点到几点干什么
Katrina: What are we doing from when to when?
Jake: 对
Jake: Yeah
Katrina: 因为就5个人
Katrina: Since there are only five of us
Katrina:  就有一点像那种市集
Katrina: It's a bit like a small market
Katrina:  但是那种市集一般都是比较大
Katrina: But those markets are usually quite big.
Katrina:  然后大家随意逛
Katrina: And everyone just strolls around.
Katrina:  但是我们这个地方比较小
Katrina: But our place is quite small.
Katrina:  那你肯定要规定一定的时间干什么
Katrina: So, you definitely need to set specific times for activities.
Katrina:  一定的时间干什么
Katrina: Specific times for activities.
Katrina:  要不然容易他们一下就看完了
Katrina: Otherwise, they might finish browsing too quickly.
Jake: 对你的拍卖可以占一点时间
Jake: Right, your auction can take up some time.
Jake: 看占多长时间
Jake: Let's see how long it takes.
Jake: 然后
Jake: Then...
Jake: 唉
Jake: Sigh.
Jake: 就这些准备都是我们这几天准备对吧
Jake: All these preparations are what we've been working on these past few days, right?
Jake: 然后别的耗时间的短剧
Jake: And other time-consuming short plays.
Jake: 跳舞吗哈哈哈
Jake: Dance, maybe? Haha.
Lucia:  哈哈我一个人跳吗
Lucia: Haha, just me dancing?
Katrina:  可以排一个简单的
Katrina: We can arrange a simple one.
Katrina: 我也可以
Katrina: I can do it too.
Jake: 以前也可以跳
Katrina: I used to dance too.
Katrina:  可以排个稍微简单点的
Katrina: We can arrange a simpler one.
Lucia: 哦那也行对
Lucia: Oh, that works too.
Jake:是吧
Jake: Right?
Lucia: 短片如果有现成的剧本的话
Lucia: If we have a ready script for a short play,
Lucia: 我们可以拍一个哈哈哈
Lucia: we can shoot one, haha.
Shure:  演其实有有点小尬
Shure: Acting can be a bit awkward.
Tasha:  嗯不如跳舞
Tasha: Hmm, dancing might be better.
Katrina:  因为那个音乐放上了
Katrina: Since we have the music.
Lucia:  不如跳舞
Lucia: Dancing might be better.
Tasha: 谈恋爱不如跳舞
Tasha: Dancing is better than dating.
Shure:  不如跳舞
Shure: Dancing is better.
Shure:  捋一下时间线吧
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Lucia: 可是跳舞的话戴眼镜会掉耶
Lucia: But if we dance, my glasses might fall off.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Shure: 还戴眼镜那时候
Shure: You still wear glasses then?
Shure:  那我们可以挑点简单的
Shure: We can choose something simple.
Shure:  蘑菇蘑菇哎
Shure: Like "Mushroom Mushroom", hey.
Lucia:  我们可以跳抖音上的那种
Lucia: We can dance to those TikTok ones.
Shure:  哈哈哈
Shure: Hahaha.
Shure:  这个听我说
Shure: Listen to me.
Shure:  谢谢你
Shure: Thank you.
Lucia: 对对对
Lucia: Yes, yes, yes.
Lucia: 抖音上就大家都可以一起挑
Lucia: On TikTok, everyone can join in together.
Lucia: 就是排的时间也会短一些对吧
Lucia: The waiting time will be shorter too, right?
Lucia: 也没有什么比较大的动作
Lucia: And there aren't any big moves.
Lucia: 戴眼镜也不影响
Lucia: Wearing glasses doesn't affect it either.
Shure:  哎
Shure: Hey.
Shure:  捋下时间线
Shure: Let's sort out the timeline.
Tasha: 可拍满100个硬币
Tasha: Can shoot for 100 coins.
Tasha: 哈哈哈啊
Tasha: Hahaha.
Katrina:  你那个
Katrina: Your...
Tasha: 没事
Tasha: It's fine.
Katrina:  我只是觉得应该拍卖10个银币
Katrina: I just think we should auction 10 silver coins.
Jake:哦好好可以买
Jake: Oh, okay, we can buy it.
Katrina:  哦哦不对
Katrina: Oh, no, wait.
Katrina:  拍卖之前首先要他们讲故事
Katrina: Before the auction, they have to tell a story.
Katrina:  才能获得那个币
Katrina: Then they can get the coin.
Jake: 对对对就是这个时间
Jake: Yes, yes, this time...
Jake: 可能就得放一个半小时了
Jake: It might have to be for an hour and a half.
Jake: 对
Jake: Right.
Jake: 就就你们昨天的那个活动
Jake: Like your event yesterday...
Jake: 也也讲那么长
Jake: Also, also tell for that long.
Shure: 也不用讲那么长
Shure: No need to tell for that long.
Shure:  就讲一个小故事
Shure: Just a short story.
Shure:  一个每个人5分钟那种大概
Shure: Like 5 minutes per person, roughly.
Jake: 哦
Jake: Oh.
Jake: 可以可以
Jake: Sure, sure.
Shure:  或者时间成本控制不好的话
Shure: Or if the time cost is out of control...
Shure:  就以其他形式获得币
Shure: They can get the coins in other ways.
Shure:  但是这个活动的核心是那个拍卖过程
Shure: But the core of this event is the auction process.
Shure:  但是这个货币怎么获得
Shure: As for how to get the coins...
Shure:  可以再进一步上去
Shure: That can be further discussed.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Shure: 拍卖过程这个是要保留的
Shure: The auction process needs to be kept.
Shure:  大概像9个人的话每个人5分钟
Shure: If there are about 9 people, then 5 minutes each...
Shure:  5945一个小时吧
Shure: It's roughly 45 minutes, an hour.
Shure:  就按一个小时算的
Shure: Just count it as an hour.
Lucia:入场给大家发一些逼
Lucia: Give everyone some coins at the entrance.
Lucia: 然后通过摇骰子让大家玩一会
Lucia: And then we'll let everyone play by rolling the dice.
Lucia: 呵呵呵
Lucia: Hehehe
Katrina: 这这像游戏
Katrina: This feels like a game.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake: 哈哈哈整点游戏
Jake: Hahaha, it's just a game.
Jake:呵整点游戏可以
Jake: Yeah, just a game.
Jake: 可以我们门门口再来一个
Jake: Let's have another one at our entrance.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Shure:  哈哈哈没有没有
Shure: Hahaha, no, no.
Lucia: 没有没有开个玩笑
Lucia: No, no, just kidding.
Katrina:  没关系很快乐
Katrina: It's okay, it's fun.
Lucia: 确实啊
Lucia: It really is.
Lucia: 这个听起来有点
Lucia: This sounds a bit...
Lucia: 哈哈哈一会发鸡蛋一会摇色子
Lucia: Hahaha, handing out eggs one moment, rolling dice the next.
Lucia: 哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha
Jake:哈哈哈哈据点是吧
Jake: Hahaha, is this a base?
Lucia: 哈哈
Lucia: Haha
Jake: 哈哈哈
Jake: Hahaha
Shure: 一锅端了
Shure: Busted all at once.
Shure:  小心这
Shure: Be careful.
Tasha: 进来玩玩嘛
Tasha: Come in and play.
Tasha: 进来就可以获得10个币
Tasha: You get 10 coins just for coming in.
Tasha: 哈哈哈
Tasha: Hahaha
Tasha: 哈哈
Tasha: Haha
Shure:  哈哈
Katrina:  但是一一进来就让
Katrina: But once you come in...
Katrina:  就是刚开始肯定要获得货币
Katrina: At the beginning, you'll definitely get some currency.
Katrina:  但是你获得货币
Katrina: But you get the currency...
Katrina:  是要他们通过讲故事的方式
Katrina: By telling stories.
Katrina:  但是他们一进来可能还没那么熟
Katrina: But when they first come in, they might not be that familiar yet.
Katrina:  就要让他们在众人面前讲故事干什么
Katrina: Asking them to tell stories in front of everyone?
Alice: 那就自我介绍
Alice: How about self-introductions?
Tasha: 会冷场
Tasha: It'll be awkward.
Alice:可以获得一个币啊
Alice: They can get one coin!
Lucia: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Lucia: Oh, self-introductions for a coin?
Lucia: 对
Lucia: Yeah.
Katrina: 啊自我介绍可以获得
Katrina: Ah, self-introductions can get you...
Alice: 第一个给5个
Alice: The first one gets 5.
Alice: 第二个给仨
Alice: The second one gets 3.
Lucia: 哈哈哈哈
Lucia: Hahaha.
Katrina:  养成机制
Katrina: Development mechanism.
Jake: 或者我们其实在这个屋子里面
Jake: Or we can actually hide some stuff in this room.
Jake: 可以藏点东西
Jake: And then...
Jake: 然后
Jake: We...
Lucia: 啊
Lucia: Ah.
Lucia: 像复活节的那种寻彩蛋游戏一样
Lucia: Like an Easter egg hunt game.
Jake: 藏点币
Jake: Hide some coins.
Shure:  藏币
Shure: Hide coins.
Jake:哦
Jake: Oh.
Shure: 也行
Shure: That works too.
Katrina:  就是刚开始自我介绍获得币
Katrina: So, at the beginning, self-introductions get coins.
Katrina:  然后玩玩点小游戏赢赢了的币
Katrina: Then, play some mini-games to win coins.
Shure:  对就比如说
Shure: Yeah, like for example...
Katrina: 说一些问答什么的
Katrina: Some Q&A stuff.
Shure:  野生动物拼图那个
Shure: That wildlife puzzle.
Lucia:  哎问答的话反正是世界地球日
Lucia: Hey, for Q&A, since it’s Earth Day...
Lucia: 对可以
Lucia: Yeah, we can.
Katrina:  知识问
Katrina: Knowledge questions.
Lucia: 知识问答小知识问答
Lucia: Trivia questions, little trivia questions.
Shure:  知识问答得币
Shure: Trivia questions to earn coins.
Shure:  对对对对对
Shure: Yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah, yeah.
Shure:  对对对好
Shure: Yeah, that’s good.
Tasha: 好
Tasha: Good.
Tasha: 世界地球日
Tasha: Earth Day.
Shure:  我想怎
Shure: I was thinking...
Tasha: 在哪一天
Tasha: What day is it?
Lucia: 二十几来着
Lucia: It’s on the 20-something.
Lucia: 2122
Lucia: 21, 22.
Katrina: 钱给让他们得到
Katrina: Let them earn money.
Jake:21来着
Jake: It’s on the 21st, I think.
Katrina:  然后再开始推销
Katrina: Then we start promoting.
Shure:  对
Shure: Right.
Katrina: 推销我们的产品
Katrina: Promote our products.